bushido um eine frage ja nicht wehren
was ist ein absolutes lieblingsgericht
ich weiß dass zum teil tunesier bist und
aus dem grund für das mich mal
interessieren worauf freust du dich wenn
du mal nach tunesien gehst was ist ein
lieblingsgericht in tunesien gut dass er
das sich zum teil tunesier bin ja aber
richtig gehört mein vater aus tunesien
es ist natürlich so dass ich dadurch
dass ich ohne meinen vater hat
aufgewachsen bin ich halt auch wenig
kontakt zu tunesien speziell habe meine
mutter aber
kocht hervorragend couscous und mit
kichererbsen und hähnchen und saison hat
daraufhin und möhren und allem drum und
dran und wenn meine mutter mich an und
sagte ja ich mache heute am couscous bin
ich natürlich extrem froh darüber und
sie macht das eigentlich glaube ich
genauso gut wie in tunesien und ich
werde dann wahrscheinlich um mal nach
tunesien fliegen und wird mal gucken wie
es da wirklich machen aber meine mama
mach das perfekt